all right some Thor 11 Thunder spoiler
talk and just letting you know right out
the gate this video is brought to you by
Magic spoon gonna talk about that a
little later but first gonna talk about
those Thor 11 Thunder spoilers and that
is a fair spoiler warning for my Thor 11
Thunder spoiler talk if you haven't seen
Thor 11 Thunder yet uh I'm not saying
you have to leave I'm just saying now
you know what you're in for I'm about to
spoil the movie does it mean you're
gonna get a lot of Grumpy Old Men energy
Jeremy in this one well probably but you
know me and optimism we got together too
young also this isn't going to be a
play-by-play they're going to be some
things I just either don't talk about or
forget to talk about so I apologize in
advance right so for Thor 11 Thunder
everything you need to know about the
tone or conflicting tone can be seen and
the first character interactions in the
movie This Christian Baylis Gore his
daughter is dying he's praying to the
gods or God to save her life it doesn't
work nothing happens this girl dies
you're in the middle of a desert then
there's this Oasis and Gore goes into it
and then there's this God that he
interacts with and these two characters
are pulled from two completely different
movies Christian Bale's giving it his
all he's plating he looks weathered
tattered on the brink of death he's
given the kind of desperate monologue
you would expect a character in his
position to give and this God is pulled
straight out of a comedy he's like he's
one of mine isn't here you can say in
context there is an artistic reason for
it to illustrate that gods are supposed
to feel like they're from a completely
different reality than Mortals I totally
get that I'm just saying Gore was great
and this God looked and felt like he was
pulled from some onstage Musical and
that's when Gore gets the sword kills
his God he's like all right I'm just
gonna kill all the gods and the reason
I'm going Occam's razor for that opening
scene and be like nah it's just
conflicting tone because like a white TV
wasn't good at blending the tone rather
than being like Oh there's this profound
reason for the two tones in that one
scene it's because I was like all right
well maybe that was what that was then
we made up a Thor and I was like okay so
Thor is riding Stormbreaker like the
wicked witch rides a broom this isn't
going to end is it this is just kind of
the movie and it is and the Bummer is
they truly he made Thor feel not only
like an idiot but like his ark is
reverting or has reverted as seen in
this scenery he's hanging out with the
Guardians of the Galaxy and they need to
help the civilization he's like okay and
he does with a massive amount of
collateral damage at least structurally
speaking in terms of buildings this
building was super important to the
civilization and he just goes through he
just blasts through it and it crumbles
in on itself like a house of cards
unpopular opinion the first Thor movie
was great still great I watched it
recently I watched all the phase one
movies recently I liked seeing the MCU
when they really felt like they had to
try it's inspiring to watch before
complacency and ego turn the MCU into
the Fatboy Slim cover but in the first
Thor he was a really arrogant person who
had zero concept of collateral damage he
was an arrogant ass and Odin was like I
need to strip you have your powers and
by the end of the movie he gave his life
to save a town full of people people who
at the beginning of the movie he kind of
saw his ants that's great that's growth
that's an arc no NOW Thor is eliminating
a threat by blasting through this
building that it's very important to the
good people of this world which is very
Thor one that's what he would have done
before he lost his power even in Thor
the Dark World there's a scene where
there's this camp this celebration going
on Thor's walking and talking away from
the camp he gets away from the camp
before he says okay Heimdall and
Heimdall summons the bifrost and
snatches Thor out why because the
bifrost is a very destructive force he
walked away from the camp before
summoning it so no one got hurt he has a
concept of action and consequence
minimizing collateral damage and Thor 11
Thunder he just summons the bifrost in a
building and blows a big hole in the
roof they'll look up through the hole
like what an idiot because he's a
complete and total clod he's now Thor
Dumber Thunder that's what I'm gonna
call him so between that and watching
Thor try to nail his old hammer for two
hours which is the real love story in
the movie I could have gone for the one
joke the scene you know where Jane has
mjolnir and he's like all right let me
just try to summon mjolnir and then
Stormbreaker comes around the corner
awkwardly it's like all right as a bit
ham-fisted but I'd take it if it was the
one joke but there's a scene where Thor
goes up to stormbreakers like scratching
Stormbreaker like it's a dog's and
pouring beer on the ax like it can drink
a beer I'm like this is [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] see the joke take the
joke screw what it does to the
characters so Jane Foster has cancer
I'll work on my Segways as the video
goes on but that's what you get now so
Jane Foster has stage four cancer I was
concerned about this about her getting
mjolnir and the powers of Flora because
I was like lifting mjolnir is a very
special thing not many have done it in
the MCU how does it do it in here and
there is this among a montage of
backstory which this movie had to do to
get you to care about Jane and Thor's
relationships all these new scenes that
took place in the past of their dating
history and it did work to make you care
about their relationship of the past
more because the James Thor things never
the strongest thing in the MCU but what
a time right when the weakest thing
about the MCU was that one relationship
that one time you know simpler times but
he tells mjolnir hey if anything happens
to me make sure you protect Jane and
that little Rune symbol comes on
millionaire so you're like oh that's a
spell that he casts on it it whether he
knew it or not I guess so Jane has
cancer she's in trouble and she feels
the cull of mjolnir and a mjolnir comes
together and gives her the powers of
Thor which the movie then illustrates is
inhibiting her body's ability to fight
the cancer
but here's to Good Intentions Hammer I
mean you're killing her faster but you
know you met well and for those of you
holding your breath yes lady Sif is in
the movie for a second I mean she's
Alive by the end she's missing an arm
but you know if she's in it you can just
tell Taiko YTD doesn't give two shits
about Thor's friends from the first two
movies he was like damn it I thought I
killed them all in Ragnarok all right
she'll lose an arm so I think it's this
bright idea because Gore is out there
killing gods and they're like all right
well we need to get the help of the Gods
so they go to the super secret place
it's kind of like that Superhero
Illuminati but it's like a god
Illuminati Russell Crowe Zeus is in it
and I actually like the fact that they
address like Thor's the God of Thunder
he's the god of lightning so there is
like Thor's like oh I modeled a lot of
me after you this is basically what the
movie is you know they're just going
from place to place in this boat being
led by screaming goats right and they
need to stop Gore from getting to the
center of the universe because he can
just make a wish and wish all the gods
away which is funny because in Thor the
Dark World Loki said that they're Gods
and Odin says they are not Gods we're
born we live we die I feel like Thor
would be like yeah it looks like all the
[ __ ] that we just fought they would
die but as guardian Gods we're pretty
mortal we're just super powerful we'll
live go for it go or make your wish so
they go to this planet which is
basically this Little Rock which
straight up reminded me of something out
of Super Mario Galaxy this is where I
said my spoiler-free video some of the
visual choices near the end were cool
because everything's in black and white
but when Jane's using mjolnir to
basically be a torch the light from
mjolnir is bringing color where it hits
but Gore one of the things he can do is
he can summon monsters from shadows and
I heard that Chris Hemsworth and taika
waititi's kids like little kids drew the
monsters or they drew the concepts from
the monsters the monsters in the movie
are based off of little kid drawings
which I don't doubt because they look
like they were based off of little kid
drawings but I feel like that's are you
using little kids as Shields I'm just
saying they're probably gonna watch
reviews and thoughts on the monsters in
the movie they're probably like oh I
wonder what they say about my monster
designs like well what am I gonna say
they were bad I'm not gonna Crush some
little kids dreams it's messed up so
these little kids were kidnapped and
captured and Thor actually backtracking
this is another scene I thought was
stupid for the sake of Comedy but it was
dumb Thor can mentally project himself
where the kids are and talk to them he's
trying to get this very important
information and valkyrie's tickling his
nose and so he's there talking to kids
and he's like what's happening and then
you see her in reality you know where
Thor's body actually is and she's
tickling his nose I'm like dude it's a
very important conversation like finding
these kids hinders on Thor getting this
information which hinders on him
concentrating which hinders on you not
actually don't [ __ ] with him don't be an
[ __ ] kids lives depend on it so
anyhow Thor gives all the kids the
powers of Thor and I was just I was
confused I didn't know we could do that
he says something like for this battle
if the kids truly believe they have the
power of Thor first of all what if you
had a kid it was just he didn't really
believe but I was also like wait could
he have done that to all the Avengers
and or Guardians of the Galaxy when they
were trying to fight Thanos no actually
one step further when he showed up to
wakanda could he have just been like all
right everyone and if you're not part of
thanos's army you have the powers of
Thor for the rest of this battle until
Thanos is defeated now Thanos has to
fight thousands of fours I didn't know
he could transfer his powers like that
but now that we know he can that kind of
breaks the movie doesn't it so anyhow
they destroy the Super Evil sword that's
corrupting Gore and then Gore uses
Stormbreaker to get to his Cosmic
wishing well and I was either going to
or not going to make his wish to make
all the gods disappear and Thor is
pretty much like ah make your wish it's
done because I think Thor actually
realized like wait a minute or not
technically gods or I'm not gonna die
it's fine yeah do your thing what's
gonna happen will happen I'm done
fighting [ __ ] you God you're about to
die and he's talking to Jane who gets
the peaceful nice death you know she
becomes light particles two time doll's
like yeah [ __ ] you I just got stabbed
and died and Gore wishes for his
daughter to get brought back and that's
his wish couple things now that Thor's
there could Thor just make any wish now
the amount of wishes I could throw into
this video I can't even I can't cover
them all I wish taka waititi didn't kill
all my friends in Ragnarok I wish than
it was never existed I wish Jane never
got cancer but the ending just bothers
me I I'm over corrupting items creating
villains the Super Evil Book corrupted
Wanda another sword corrupts Gore it's
like why do we need items to create
villains it's not remotely as
interesting or relatable as villains
just being villains because they believe
what they're doing is best why couldn't
gorgeous be like gods or dicks I think
I'm gonna kill them all and have that be
enough it's like the great Cain told
Raziel revenge is motivation enough at
least it's honest it's true I felt like
Gore had all the motivation in the world
to slaughter Gods why not have that be
enough why do we have to be like oh he
had this corrupting sword which is now
shattered why because we need this
moment where Gore just cries and he's
super sad and now we're supposed to
empathize and sympathize with him and
then he dies and now Thor's like oh [ __ ]
I just became a dad I have to look after
this wish kid that just came out of
nowhere
damn it but that's who they are and
that's where the title comes from
because uh Korg who I thought died at a
point it gets blasted and I'm like oh
cork just died nope he's a face that
they pal around with and then by the end
of the movie he just has his body bag
but apparently Thor and this little girl
are known as love and Thunder
so the mid credit and post-credit scenes
are a mid-credits scene Jane Foster
appears in Valhalla and Idris elbus
there heimdall's there which was great
to see him again he was like you can
take your place in Valhalla if you want
and then the end credit scene is again
Zeus is alive because we thought he died
he got a whole blast to throw him nope
Zeus is alive because death meets very
little in the MCU he's talking to
somebody and that's somebody's Hercules
and he's pretty much like get revenge in
Hercules is like yes Father which is
great um given the timeline Adam Warlock
was teased in a post-credit scene about
five years ago so we'll see Hercules on
his revenge quest in about
eight years guys in the end Thor 11
Thunder it's one of these movies I feel
like you can find a reason or two to
have fun with it you can also find 52
reasons for it to bother you for me I'm
a big fan of character continuity and
World continuity and this just kind of
breaks it for the sake of Comedy I
usually watch the movie again before I
do a spoiler video I just didn't I don't
know what my rating means now because
I'm like a good time if you're drunk
this would have been a great time to
test that hypothesis but I'll leave that
to you if you're among the legal
drinking age and drink responsibly tell
me how that goes it's the MCU right now
it does feel directionless and does feel
like it's lost a bit of that MCU magic
but what does have its magic that would
be this video sponsor magic spoon nailed
it because magic spoon seriously I'm not
stopping because no matter who we are
most of us can agree cereal still holds
a place in the pantheon of meals maybe
you need a quick breakfast a midnight
snack that is for adults now we got to
start thinking healthier enter magic
spoon they're a high protein low carb
zero grams of sugar healthier solution
bowl of cereal and they have a myriad of
flavor choices but don't get locked in
hello Coco hello cookies and cream mix
it together hello cocoa cookies and
cream and as I said it's a healthier
bowl of cereal with gluten-free grain
free high protein low carb and zero
grams of sugar also this is voice over
because don't talk with your mouth full
that's rude and they even have cereal
bars so if you need an even quicker
quick bite to eat in the morning they
got you covered so click the link below
go to magicspoon.com use coat Johns for
five dollars off your order all right so
Thor 11 Thunder have you seen it what
did you think about it and actually
what's a good Gore comic book a comic
book Arc with Gore I want to see what
all the fuss is about what did you think
of the movie and do you have an answer
to that whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]